bonjour pour les portes ouvertes
au Collège militaire royal de Saint-Jean
on ne veut pas manquer l'occasion de
faire bonne impression auprès de
potentiels recrues si vous décidez
vraiment de venir ici la plupart sont
des jeunes à la recherche d'un projet
pour poursuivre leurs études au milieu
du groupe il y a cet homme qui attire
l'attention
David guetter est un décrocheur il a
fait sa carrière dans la construction
aujourd'hui ils se sont prêts à
s'asseoir sur les bancs d'école pour
réaliser son rêve d'aller voir des
sinistrés fait le sauvetage des familles
pris dans les régions qui ont pas d'aide
j'aimerais ça pas mal plus que la guerre
c'est le genre de recrue qui tombe à
point pour la ministre de la défense
avec
l'oringuant avec l'effort les feux de
forêt tout le monde les jeunes assez
aussi depuis plus de
voir des opportunités ça c'est vraiment
notre raison d'être la Major Général
lisburgon est responsable des ressources
humaines dans les forces armées c'est
elle qui a la mission de regarnir les
rangs montrer aux Canadiens le rôle des
Forces armées canadiennes domestiquement
mais aussi internationalement c'est je
pense que quand je regarde la ma
carrière les temps où je me suis senti
le plus le plus fier c'est quand j'étais
capable d'aider les communautés même si
déjà c'est comme remplir des sacs de
sable
l'armée canadienne a lancé en 2010
l'opération lancius qui a pour mission
de répondre aux besoins de la population
canadienne lors de catastrophes
naturelles comme on l'a vu récemment
lors du passage de l'ouragan Fiona
depuis sa création l'opération lent a
donné lieu à 38 interventions dans cette
seulement en 2021
au début des années 90 donc pour moi
l'argument de vente pour moi
principalement c'était l'idée du soldat
de la paix Bruno Charbonneau et
maintenant professeur au collège royal
militaire de Saint-Jean selon lui c'est
la réponse à la crise climatique qui
doit aujourd'hui faire partie de
l'argument de vente des forces armées il
met la main à un nouveau programme de
baccalauréat qui verra le jour en 2024
du point de vue d'Ottawa le fait qu'ils
approuvent qu'on construit ce programme
là aussi reflet je pense les besoins des
Forces canadiennes tel qu'il les perçoit
même des besoins qui ne se limitent pas
aux opérations en territoire canadien au
sommet de juin 2021 le temps a annoncé
qu'elle voulait être l'organisation
internationale qu'elle est menée un peu
l'agenda et définir l'agenda de la
sécurité climatique et dans ce contexte
le Canada a annoncé la création d'être
l'autre d'un centre d'excellence de
tasse sur cette question là si on met
tous ensemble je pense qu'effectivement
on pourrait repenser ou redéfinir ou
ajuster la mission des forces ah le
mission primordiale c'est de défendre le
Canada le général à la retraite anjoule
Leslie a été chef d'état-major de
l'armée de terre et il a siégé comme
député libérales à Ottawa il est scepté
face à ce virage le gouvernement
libéraux sont des passifs ils ne
comprend pas l'utilité des forces
et le rôle
ultime de l'armée canadienne comme on
voit aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se passe
à l'Europe c'est être prêt à battre
contre un ennemi qui se fait avant et
après l'année académique david lui devra
se battre contre un autre jardinier pour
réaliser son rêve qu'est-ce qu'il fait
le plus peur c'est les études
je pensais pas que c'était autant
d'études mais j'aurais très pas chaque
rêve il y a des défis ça peut pas se
faire aussi facile que ça
reste au Canada Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu